we do have time to make sure you are  aware of a fatal  auto pedestrian hit and run crash this  in the near southwest valley has  completely shut down jones between  flamingo and tropicana the crash  occurring at harmon here's our live  picture with the intersection closed  there are the regional transportation  commission you can see all of the metro  police vehicles there we have our own  photographer on the scene there's  armando's picture with the yellow police  tape this is across jones  between flamingo and tropicana so back  to the traffic map to give you the  detours with jones closed pretty simple  head over to the east for decatur or go  west to rainbow for your north south  travel i would skip harmon through there  as well because of the ongoing  investigation flamingo and trop will get  through there heather